- [Voiceover] What I
hope to do in this video
is look at this graph y is equal to f of x
and think about the intervals
where this graph is positive or negative
and then think about the intervals
when this graph is
increasing or decreasing.
So first let's just think
about when is this function,
when is this function positive?
Well positive means that the value
of the function is greater than zero.
It means that the value
of the function this means
that the function is
sitting above the x-axis.
So it's sitting above the x-axis
in this place right over here
that I am highlighting in
yellow and it is also sitting
above the x-axis over here.
And if we wanted to, if we wanted
to write those intervals mathematically.
Well let's see, let's say that this point,
let's say that this point
right over here is x equals a.
Let's say that this right
over here is x equals b and
this right over here is x equals c.
Then it's positive, it's
positive as long as x is
between a and b.
At x equals a or at x equals b the value
of our function is zero but it's positive
when x is between a and b, a and b
or if x is greater than c.
X is, we could write it
there, c is less than x
or we could write that
x is greater than c.
These are the intervals when
our function is positive.
Let me write this, f of x, f of x positive
when x is in this
interval or this interval
or that interval.
So when is f of x negative?
Let me do this in another color.
F of x is going to be negative.
Well, it's gonna be negative
if x is less than a.
So this is if x is less than
a or if x is between b and c
then we see that f of
x is below the x-axis.
F of x is down here so this
is where it's negative.
So here or, or x is between
b or c, x is between b and c.
And I'm not saying less than or equal to
because at b or c the value of
the function f of b is zero,
f of c is zero.
That's where we are actually
intersecting the x-axis.
So that was reasonably straightforward.
Now let's ask ourselves
a different question.
When is the function
increasing or decreasing?
So when is f of x, f of x increasing?
Well increasing, one way to
think about it is every time
that x is increasing then
y should be increasing
or another way to think
about it, you have a,
you have a positive rate of
change of y with respect to x.
We could even think about it as imagine
if you had a tangent line
at any of these points.
If you had a tangent line at
any of these points the slope
of that tangent line is
going to be positive.
But the easiest way for
me to think about it is
as you increase x you're
going to be increasing y.
So where is the function increasing?
Well I'm doing it in blue.
So it's increasing right until we get
to this point right over
here, right until we get
to that point over there
then it starts decreasing
until we get to this
point right over here and
then it starts increasing again.
It starts, it starts increasing again.
So let me make some more labels here.
So let's say that this,
this is x equals d and
that this right over here,
actually let me do that in green color,
so let's say this is x equals d.
Now it's not a, d, b but you
get the picture and let's say
that this is x is equal to, x is equal to,
let me redo it a little
bit, x is equal to e.
X is equal to e.
So when is this function increasing?
Well it's increasing if x is
less than d, x is less than d
and I'm not gonna say
less than or equal to
'cause right at x equals
d it looks like just
for that moment the
slope of the tangent line
looks like it would be,
it would be constant.
We're going from increasing to decreasing
so right at d we're neither
increasing or decreasing.
But then we're also increasing,
so if x is less than d
or x is greater than e,
or x is greater than e.
And where is f of x decreasing?
So f of x, let me do this
in a different color.
When is, let me pick a
mauve, so f of x decreasing,
decreasing well it's going
to be right over here.
It's gonna be right between d and e.
Between x equals d and x equals e
but not exactly at those points
'cause at both of those points
you're neither increasing nor decreasing
but you see right over
here as x increases,
as you increase your x
what's happening to your y?
If you go from this point
and you increase your x
what happened to your y?
Your y has decreased.
You increase your x, your y has decreased,
you increase your x, y has decreased,
increase x, y has decreased all the way
until this point over here.
So f of x is decreasing
for x between d and e.
So hopefully that gives
you a sense of things.
Notice, these aren't the same intervals.
That we are, the intervals
where we're positive
or negative don't perfectly coincide
with when we are increasing or decreasing.
So it's very important to
think about these separately
even though they kinda sound the same.